Problem Solver I'm able to be observant
because that's women's gift is being
observant for social situations that's
why women are socially Superior to men
okay it's never sexist when a guy
mentions something about a woman that's
positive so a woman's job is to use that
social calibration that they have that
they're Superior to men in and be able
to be like okay this guy's deficient in
this and deficient of this Etc let me
come in compliment make this guy operate
he's already operating at 95 I'm going
to get him to 102. and when you're at a
high level already that extra two three
four five percent is what helps you beat
the competition this guy's dangerous
women will do that that a lot of women
will give you that life that will give
you that balance they will compliment
you but they're not going to just do it
until you're
question am I socially Superior
on the podcast
I'm just asking I'm just asking serious
you know because men like to play the
field for a very long time when you're
with a guy of value you got to
understand that he has the leverage not
you you're applying to be his girlfriend
I wear the highway baby because at the
end of the day when you can replace a
girl that's when she respects you it's
on the woman to prove to me that she's
worthy of a relationship that's where a
lot of girls make a mistake they'll sit
there and say I'm good I'm loyal blah
blah blah blah I want to you know see
how you do before you get promoted I'm
not going to give a girl the position of
a secretary or under boss right or
second in charge of my company unless
she's been vetted she's got to work her
way up the problem is that we give women
CEO jobs when they haven't proven
themselves and they don't respect the
job who's listening to this man so
you're here's the thing you're looking
at equality from a human perspective I'm
not saying that men are better than
women from a human perspective I'm
saying that men are leaders
he's right
let's say I just use NBA players because
I just feel like those are guys
entertainers athletes they just
have women on tap I'm sorry
that was those the wives are all getting
cheated on they know it
we don't I don't say right or wrong I
can't tell the world how to be that's my
opinion on it I can't
Ali
I'm eating
therefore we cannot be equal when you're
on the battlefield right and the
lieutenant or whoever the the commanding
officer is on the battlefield you're not
equal to him as you know a regular
Soldier he is the leader you're not
equal but there's a reason there's a
hierarchy to dictate order if the woman
is equal to the guy well who's going to
make the final decision nothing gets
done by a committee they're always
asking Pearl was born a bit ugly it's
unfortunate why
rude rude but hitting the gym styling
hair and clothing can up her game
[Laughter]
look it I can't really help how my face
looks
I was just born like that
they just not call me ugly anymore can
we just not I just appreciate it
who am I talking about I'm just getting
old
I'm just tired of this one leader in
charge there's a reason why there's a
president there's a CEO Etc both people
can't be Alphas as they say the problem
is this women are confused about what
men actually want they think a CEO a
boss a business owner ambitious uh
competitive woman we don't give a [ __ ]
about none of that stuff men don't care
about that and I would argue the more
money a man makes the less he cares
about his woman's ability to earn money
men and women are not the same women
basically become the very men that they
want to attract yeah but the thing is
why so men like I find the memo say that
they do you guys think you are what you
attract yes or no
because I feel like that was a bad piece
of dating advice that I got like become
what you want to attract Ellie
can you chill the F out you're gonna get
you're getting kicked out
you're getting kicked out
um
all right I'm gonna give you a little
piece of meat to leave me the hell alone
okay
that's what I'm gonna do come here
leave me alone leave me alone you crazy
dog it's on the ground look turn up
sorry she was driving me nuts
women that have ambitioned to start it
was what makes Delight to get laid no I
wouldn't say it's even a liar it's a
lady it's not because for me like
whenever like I've dated and stuff like
that a lot of men say they like the fact
that I am ambitious that I haven't no
but I'm saying in general a lot of men
get irritated like nowadays like so
you're so you're dating all these women
and you're gonna say all these women do
this is they do nothing and they expect
but that's the qualities that a
traditional woman would bring she'd want
a man to do things for her so but here's
the thing she look it
I'm sorry men don't care about your
career I do well
I would say I'm pretty successful for my
age you know guys don't give a [ __ ] it
does not make me more attractive to a
guy they're like yeah cool and
they don't care they just don't care I
can't make the world
yeah
it would be helpful to me if they cared
but I can't make them care
people mess that man's life so do you
want a relationship
monogamous
so how many girlfriends do you want
I mean as many as I can I mean I
probably have four wives I think I could
do four this man wants four wives he's
going back 500 years four wives the way
to go because if one acts stupid you can
go ahead and get another one breeding
yeah
yeah why okay what's up I asked my dad
about this four wives he said have
before they get four
I said dad you're too blue pill you're
blue pill
most guys that are monogamous are
monogamous
out of force la la my dad would never la
la
if I land at 100 dudes and I said listen
man
you keep your girlfriend
right no don't line up my dad or my
brothers I don't want to hear it she's
not gonna care he's gonna take it every
most guys have to kind of concede to
what their girl wants should I call my
brother I'm gonna call him is he gonna
lie to me and let me know in the chat
um
Adam
okay let's call them let's call him
will he answer
I've been bad for answering today
foreign
damn
people are leaving me on
anyways
wait with the frick
stupid quote happy wife happy life I
think that's the dumbest quote ever I
mean it's a good quote absolutely not
why because a woman's job is to please
the man not the other way around a
woman's job is to place each other
women are pleased by being with the best
man
in in the area that women are pleased by
you being the best version of yourself
as a man gains more status success
income Etc the woman wins she's all his
success she benefits from that it's not
the same
I died I'm not sure
yeah because women women don't like guys
don't care about your success like
they're happy for you they're like cool
babe but
are they attracted to it no no I don't
make the world I don't I'm just telling
you what it is
five dollar Super Chat Pearl isn't ugly
plain but still cute
she gets points for chewing with her
mouth closed and being tall always
wanted a woman I could go up on go up on
ew what
ew
anyways
um
hey yeah yeah
yeah Etc and she starts to outgrow her
man she's gonna look for a better man
men and women are not the same but some
women we are emotional beans like we
will stay with them no but we will stay
with the man like if a man loves us and
his lawyer we will stay really is that
why women initiate an overwhelming
amount of the breakups
um
women also one of the number one
indicators we're going to leave your ass
is if we start start out earning you we
get a promotion at work
like yeah because they're emotional and
they're loyal no women are the list most
disloyal creatures
which is okay
yeah and I hated that when I first heard
it I was like what no I'm loyal
he's right he's right if a dude's
bumming at for so long at some point
you're out you're out you're not gonna
take care of him
so do you like the whole sugar baby kind
of Lifestyle Manukau to the woman that's
you no no that sounds like it like you
want to be this provider so that sounds
like it well here's the thing but then
you moan about women for doing that so
you know I accept that women are are
um hypergamous creatures that want to
get their needs met through men I accept
this reality and I've accepted it a long
time ago I'm a firm believer that men
need to be men men need to lead women
follow men pay for dates men should
provide men should be Breadwinners I
think women working should be elected I
don't think it should be mandatory these
guys definitely a sugar daddy
look at no girl's gonna argue with that
no girl's gonna argue you go to work for
fun
um I've always
I was never minded working
but [ __ ] no no girl's gonna argue so
guys all the time going sugar sites and
use them to date because there's a lot
of girls on there that aren't
necessarily how do I say this
sugar babies that are just looking to be
taken care of and paid an allowance
there's a good amount of girls on there
that make their own money or and or just
want to deal with a guy that has his
stuff together let's be honest tender
Bumble hinge these traditional dating
apps they fail 90 plus percent of them
and the stats show that how you meet a
woman matters a lot more than meeting
the woman what I mean by that is that
women place a lot of importance in the
context under which they meet you it's
my job as a man to not get finessed
that's true that is very true
I'm way more likely to talk to a guy if
I meet him through mutual friends than
if I met him like through answers as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and demonetized on a daily
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible